cuál función no tiene intersección con
el eje x y aquí nos dan tres funciones f
x gx y hd x antes que nada pensemos en
qué significa tener una intersección con
el eje x pues significa que el valor de
la coordenada ye tiene que ser cero o si
la coordenada ya está dada por una
función como efe vh entonces simplemente
significa que la función tiene que valer
0 de modo que esta pregunta es
equivalente a cuál de las siguientes
funciones nunca es cero
vamos en orden consideremos primero fx
tengo que fx es igual a x al cuadrado
más 5 ahora aquí sucede algo interesante
x al cuadrado es una función que es no
negativa es decir para cualquier x real
x al cuadrado o es 0 o es mayor que 0 y
5 es una constante de modo que todo esto
todo esto es mayor o igual a 5 para
cualquier valor de x eso significa que
en fx no puede ser cero porque 0 es
menor que 5 otro moverlo es imagínense
qué pasaría si yo obligar a la función a
valer 0 entonces tendría que 0 es igual
a alguna x al cuadrado más 5 si resuelve
esto para x sumando menos 5 de ambos
lados obtendría que menos 5 es igual a x
al cuadrado de donde si tomo la raíz
cuadrada positiva obtengo que menos 5 en
raíz cuadrada tiene que ser igual a x
pero esto no tiene ningún sentido sobre
los números reales
no hay ningún valor de x que me pueda
satisfacer esto de modo que al menos
ésta no tiene intersecciones con el eje
x que de las demás pues aquí vemos que
por ejemplo gtx vale 0 precisamente
cuando x vale 0
esa es una intersección con él con el
eje x sería este punto la función que
corta el eje x al menos en este punto
quizás haya más y que hay de hd x pues
aquí de hecho lo tenemos visualmente hdx
corta el eje x precisamente aquí en
menos 6 así que hdx también t en la
intersección con el eje x de modo que la
única función que no tiene intersección
con el eje x es f